[APPLAUSE]
WESLEY CHAN: By the way, I
met Alan about 20 years ago
when they first started touring.
ALAN PARSONS: Oh, turn around.
Turn around and show them.
WESLEY CHAN: A long time ago.
They did not tour when they
were actually on all the charts.
ALAN PARSONS: Unlike
a Spinaltap t-shirt,
it doesn't say "cancelled"
against half of them.
WESLEY CHAN: That's good,
because sometimes I feel
personally cancelled.
All right, so I'll let Alan
and Julian take it away.
And I'll be back to
moderate afterwards.
All right, you guys.
It's all yours.
ALAN PARSONS: For those
of you who don't know,
this is Wesley Chan.
What's your official
title again?
WESLEY CHAN: Developer Advocate.
ALAN PARSONS:
Developer Advocate.
WESLEY CHAN: I teach
outside engineers
how to integrate Google
technologies into the apps
that they build-- web or mobile.
So I'm basically
your public face
for all you guys who are in
Android or work on product.
ALAN PARSONS: I
find it incredible
that you don't all
know each other.
But then I found out
there's 20,000 of you.
[LAUGHING]
That's pretty amazing.
So we don't really
have a prepared speech,
but Julian insisted.
And I kind of read
through this this morning.
As Wes kindly mentioned, we are
promoting this book right here.
Although I don't think it's
fair to do shameless promotion
for the entire hour.
JULIAN COLBECK: This book
is based on a DVD series
that we produced
a few years ago.
And the kind of genesis
of why we did that
is the incredible
democratization
of recording
technology, which has
put wonderful tools
in people's hands.
But rather like just
handing somebody a plane
and say, well, take
off and fly it home,
to put a kind of recording
studio on a laptop in front
of people and expect them to
be able to make a decent record
is pretty unrealistic.
And Alan worked for
five, six years before
he became an engineer,
nevermind a producer,
and that kind of high flying
studio person, and recording
is complicated.
There's a lot of moving parts.
So that was the reason that we
wrote this book, to help people
who have kind of grown up
in a digital, plug-in based,
DAW based world, to
kind of introduce
some of the traditional
class concepts of recording
and help them kind of
go through that maze.
ALAN PARSONS: How many of you
have home recording facilities?
JULIAN COLBECK: Right.
ALAN PARSONS: Lots.
Lots.
JULIAN COLBECK: And so when
it came to the book idea--
we are going
backwards, I think we
are working the t-shirt next.
ALAN PARSONS:
Actually everybody who
has a computer in front of them
should have put their hand up
because a laptop is a
recording studio these days.
Well, we'll qualify that.
JULIAN COLBECK: In
varying degrees.
But I think one of the
interesting kind of threads
that rums through both
the book and the DVD--
the video series-- is the
nature of what is good audio.
Is there a fixed
definition of good audio?
And if so, is it fixed in
terms of it's a constant,
or does it change with the
equipment and fashion and time?
If there is such a thing,
how do we achieve it?
And is there a point nowadays
in trying to go for excellence?
Alan gave the keynote address
at the Audio Engineering Society
in Los Angeles last month.
And it's supposed to be a kind
of fairly platitudeness bland
occassion, and
Alan came out there
and started ripping into
microphone manufacturers
and this and that.
And then he said
at one point, how
the hell did we let MP3 happen?
[GIBBERISH]
ALAN PARSONS: And then there
was a rousing applause.
And I said, how did we
allow MP3 to happen?
And everyone went, yeah!
And then here was the sad
thing at the end of the talk.
WESLEY CHAN: In terms
of quality or in terms
of being able to move
around the music faster?
ALAN PARSONS: In
terms of quality.
Just quality.
No, absolutely it's a great
way to move around and access
lots of different
kinds of music quickly.
But just to finish this little--
JULIAN COLBECK:
But the problem was
is right in front is the guy who
invented MP3, who was literally
in front of him.
ALAN PARSONS: He came and
shook hands afterwards
and said, by the
way, I invented MP3.
Pleased to meet you.
JULIAN COLBECK: So we moved
on very hastily from that.
But my theory is that
audio is a bit like shoes.
No matter how sharply you dress,
if you're wearing crap shoes,
it's not going to
work as an outfit.
I mean, your shoes
will give you away.
And equally, if you
got really sharp shoes,
no matter how sloppily
you're dressing,
you're going to
look pretty cool.
And I think audio
is a bit like that.
I mean, in a movie you
can have jerky frames
and a sloppy script, and a
badly put together image,
but if the sounds
is good, it's going
to look and feel
kind of professional.
And audio is a very
important thing,
which I think a lot of
people now overlook.
ALAN PARSONS: It's always
the poor relation in movies,
unfortunately.
JULIAN COLBECK: That's right.
ALAN PARSONS: It's
always the last thing
to get talked about or budgeted.
JULIAN COLBECK: Right.
Or studied even.
I think nowadays when you got
such a preponderance of people
who are making their
own videos and stuff,
audio is a kind of afterthought.
They're like, oh, shit.
Now what do I do?
You know, but they don't
put the same focus into that
as they do the images and
I think at a great loss.
And I think that also
badly recorded tracking
of a great song is always
going to sound like a demo.
And a really well
recorded tracked,
even if the song is
a little bit iffy,
is always going to
sound professional.
So I think there are many
reasons to kind of study
what it is that
makes good audio.
And that's one of the things
that we kind of thread
through this whole
series and the book--
how to get good audio.
One of the stories
that Alan will tell,
which always really
kind of amazed
me was when Alan was
working with The Beatles
with Paul McCartney,
well, take on the story
of what he use to torment with.
ALAN PARSONS: Paul
would always say,
I think we can get
a better sound on--
JULIAN COLBECK: Anything.
ALAN PARSONS: --this instrument
or let's get a better
vocal sound.
And then you would
scratch your head
and say, well, how do
I make this better?
I'll change the mic,
I'll try a different EQ,
I'll try different effects.
But he never was able
to actually describe
what he was looking
for until he heard it.
So that was the
challenge as an engineer,
to just work hard
until you found
something that was
turning him on.
JULIAN COLBECK:
Did you ever end up
with a kind of definition of
what it was that he meant?
ALAN PARSONS: No.
No.
It was always very vague.
I mean, not just Paul, I
mean, people would say,
I think we need a more
aggressive snare sound.
Aggressive, OK.
Where's the button
master aggression.
But God bless him.
Producers weren't
necessarily qualified
as engineers back in the day.
Almost all of them
are now qualified.
In fact, the job description
has become extremely vague.
I mean, musicians, writers,
producers, engineers, computer
operators, they can
all be one person
now, which is interesting.
But in my recent
work I've chosen
to abandon some of the things
that I used to do in the past.
And I used to operate 10
machines on my own sessions.
But now if I'm using Pro
Tools or Cubase or something,
I will have an operator
in the room, a guys that
does the computing stuff.
And also means there is
somebody to make the coffee
and tea and stuff like that.
But I've always maintained
that producers, engineers
need an assistant.
I think a lot of
engineers and producers
try to do too much from
a technical standpoint,
and then lose ground
on the creative stuff.
So I don't feel I am paid
to click a mouse all day.
I concentrate on
music and the micing
and the performance, the
songs, all that stuff.
Any observations from
anybody about that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN COLBECK: It was all arms.
Yeah.
ALAN PARSONS: Well,
I actually don't
remember because I was taking
too many drugs at the time.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
the questions, please?
ALAN PARSONS: OK.
He asked a general
question about how
"Dark Side of the
Moon" came about.
I was actually on the
staff at Abbey Road.
I had, kind of by
default-- because I'd
been the tap operator
on the sessions--
I knew the music on "Atom Heart
Mother," the previous album.
So I got the job to mix that.
And it seems I did
a reasonable job
and they asked me to come in
and do "Dark Side of the Moon."
So it was just literally
just a staff engineer
working for the act that
had booked the studio.
And I was paid 35 pounds
a week, plus overtime.
So contrary to popular
belief, I did not
get rich on "Dark
Side of the Moon."
The problem, as you put
it, was that the band
didn't seem to have
the time to come
and watch me do the mixing.
It wasn't a perfect mix,
it was done quickly.
It was done in five or six days.
It was just me and Peter
James, the tape op.
And it wasn't perfect.
But it had a certain magic.
I think we retained a
certain something that James
got through his mix in
later years did not have.
But that mix is now
officially out in the shops
on the immersive box set.
So anybody who has a surround
system, which I encourage
everybody to do,
because it's great.
Yeah, it's out there.
Was there a specific problem
that you heard about it?
AUDIENCE: No.
I was just wondering.
I had heard like
that they didn't
think the spoken voices
were loud enough.
I just heard weird
things about it.
I just wondered if you
could put that to rest?
ALAN PARSONS: The
band said that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I just heard that they didn't
like it for some reasons.
I wondered what they were.
ALAN PARSONS: I think
I would acknowledge
that there were certain things
missing because they were spun
in on the final mix
and the stereo version.
And I didn't know
where those tapes were.
All kinds of little
things like that.
Just tiny little
insurgent voices that only
a real Pink Floyd connoisseur
would even notice.
But it was fun.
It was fun to do.
And I think it sounds really
good now, 40 years later.
AUDIENCE: Somebody leaked
that mix a while ago.
And it was available on
the internet as a rip.
And before that--
ALAN PARSONS: Oh,
there were plenty
of bootleg versions of it.
AUDIENCE: Can you
speak into the mic?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: So you implied earlier
and talked about the changing
views of what
constitutes good audio.
And I'm wondering to what extent
you think those changes result
from fashion and to what extent
they come from new technologies
and recording?
JULIAN COLBECK:
Well, one thing I
was going to just
kind of briefly
touch on before we get there,
but is relevant to that
is that there is sound
and we are humans.
And sound is what
sound is, and we
can hear approximately
20 hertz to 20k,
given age and
infirmity, et cetera.
I believe the figure--
ALAN PARSONS: (MUMBLED)
As we get older--
[GIBBERISH]
JULIAN COLBECK: It
sounds a bit [INAUDIBLE].
I think we're capable of
hearing a dynamic range of one
to a trillion.
And an orchestra would
probably have 50 dB of--
ALAN PARSONS: 40 to 50.
On CD, it could be greater.
On digital recordings,
it could be greater.
But on vinyl and tape you were
at the mercy of the background
noise.
JULIAN COLBECK: So we as
humans, and sound as an entity
is clearly much bigger
than any technology.
ALAN PARSONS: It's a
fascinating thing, actually,
to test your ear.
I mean, there are
programs online
to test hearing through
headphones and stuff.
And you would be
quite surprised,
especially if you do it
over a period of time.
This young man here,
he can probably
hear about 17 kilohertz.
And I think the highest
I can hear now is 12.
JULIAN COLBECK: Really?
I don't think I'm
even that high.
AUDIENCE: I did
want to ask how you
deal with changes
in your hearing?
Any thoughts on that?
I
ALAN PARSONS: Think the
aging process in hearing
is forgiving enough
for us to know still
how to compensate for it.
You don't actually notice it.
I mean, good music still
sounds like good music to me.
I don't sort of knowingly miss
the high frequency content
that I've lost.
I mean, for heaven's
sake, George Martin
was producing records
well into his 80s
and managed to still
get good results.
And to a certain extent you
can rely on others, as well.
But I still feel like I
can judge a good sound
with my limited hearing.
I mean, I hate to use that word
but isn't getting any better
and nor is it for anybody.
We're all in a state
of slowly deteriorating
high frequency content
in our hearing.
He said the music is
in the range that--
JULIAN COLBECK: Mid range.
ALAN PARSONS: --the seniors
amongst us can here.
But there are endless
arguments about how
frequencies beyond the
normal range of hearing
actually affect it.
AUDIENCE: The
Zildjian aficionados.
ALAN PARSONS: Zildjian
aficionados, yes.
Is that what you are?
AUDIENCE: I don't
hear that well.
ALAN PARSONS: Yeah, I mean
technically a symbol crash is
[IMITATES CRASH]
And I might be hearing it as a
[LOWER CRASH]
AUDIENCE: Question over here.
So this is a very
engineering audience here,
so I'm going to leave the
psychoacoustics and some
of the art elements for
later, but to start us off
with a hardcore
engineering question,
let's hear your
opinion about how
to best optimize an audio chain.
So starting with the
microphones and then
like all of the other stuff
until the recording device.
Where do you see in today's
technology landscape would
be most utility per buck if
somebody was allocating pieces
of his hard-earned
money into a chain?
ALAN PARSONS: You
get what you pay for.
I've never been a great
advocate of specifying
a certain microphone, a certain
mic preamp, a certain chain,
a certain limiter, a certain
capacitor, because in my home
environment, I
know what I've got.
I know how it behaves.
I know how to best use it.
If I walk into a studio
I've never been in before,
I'll take what they've got.
There's a sort of
motto of mine, it
doesn't matter what it
is, we'll make it great.
I'm not going to line up to 10
different microphones and A-B
one against the other and ten
different mic preamps and ten
different A to D
converters or whatever.
I'm just going to say, well,
let's see how it sounds.
Yeah.
Sounds good.
Let's go with it.
JULIAN COLBECK:
I'm thinking back
in the day in the '70s
or '60s and '70s, there
were no such thing as
kind of separate mic pre's
that you chose.
It was the desk.
And the mic pre's were
whatever was on the desk.
And I think one of
the points that Alan
makes throughout this book
and the series is not so much
that you have to have this
particular widget, gadget,
plugin, whatever in
order to make this music,
but you need the
knowledge to make
whatever you have sound good.
And that is a very
important point.
Because I think if
you have the ability
to get a decent recording
out of a modest mic
or in a modest environment,
then you can do anything.
But if you are only capable of
EQ-ing something on a Fairchild
or only capable--
you're very limited.
ALAN PARSONS: There's one
story in the book, which
which when you get it, as I hope
you will-- I see a lot of you
got it already--
Sylvia Massy, who
is a celebrated
engineer originally
from one of the
southern states, anyway
she's a very, very
respected engineer.
She had a producer
who insisted that they
try a whole bunch of
different microphones
to make sure that
they were getting
the best possible vocal sound.
So they lined up literally
tens of thousands
of dollars worth
of microphones--
a Norman 47, a
Telefunken 451, AKG C 12,
all kinds of mics-- and
also some cheaper mics.
Notably a Shure 57.
And guess what one?
$100 microphone.
SM 57 won the shootout
for best vocal sound.
I mean it's unbelievable.
JULIAN COLBECK: But
I think that now we
do live in a kind of very gear
obsessed and obsessive world.
I think that in the kind of
hey day of analogue recording,
I mean, was there such a
kind of an obsession with
the equipment?
Or was it more--
ALAN PARSONS: No.
I mean it was down
to the relationship
between the artist and
producer and engineer.
The producer was
there to make sure
that the artist performed well.
And he would very much rely
on the skills of the engineer
to balance the best sound.
When I first started
at Abbey Road Studios,
we were called
Balance Engineers, not
Recording Engineers.
So the tape operators
were officially
known as button pushers.
So that's how I started off.
I started off as a button
pusher and then graduated
to being a balance engineer.
But I think it's
true to say that so
much of the art of
engineering is about balance.
Just finding the right
mix between instruments,
the vocals, effects, whatever.
It's all about the balance.
And the skill of the engineer
is to balance the sound such
that it brings the
best out of the artist
and gives the producer
what he wants.
You going to pass
the mic back there?
Oh, you got it already.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Got it right here.
Thanks very much for
coming down here.
Very cool.
Great to see you guys.
But I got the book.
I'm going to read
it, but I would just
love for you guys to just
walk through the high level
kind of elevator
pitch of production.
We all have our home
studios, we're all
passionate about
music in some respect,
and we all have
our own homegrown
like what we gather
together and piece together
to get these represented song
ideas that are in our heads
to get them out into the world.
But it'd be great to just
hear you guys walk through,
like you start
with the song idea,
then you get a click track, you
figure out the arrangement, you
get the arrangement
on a click track,
and then take us through
kind of like the steps,
whether you do drums first,
or you record a rhythm
guitar that the drummer plays
to, and then how you overdub,
the pros and cons of
doing a live recording
with multiple people or
just starting with drums,
then doing bass, how do
you see that going out
into a home studio?
JULIAN COLBECK: I think you've
named all the ways of doing it.
ALAN PARSONS: The
piecemeal approach
is something I've
never supported.
I've always tried to get at
least three or four people
playing together at once.
The more the merrier.
The more they interact,
the better the feel is.
If it's just a bass
player and a click track,
it's not going to
be exciting is it?
I mean, let's face it.
And I've always
supported the notion
that if you're going to
make a rock and roll record,
have a rock and roll band.
I recognize that people do it.
JULIAN COLBECK: I was going to
say that technology does allow
you to do what you only can
do and most people don't
have access to an entire band or
anyplace that they could record
that band and
therefore you start
with a click track and a bass.
And can you make good records?
I think you can.
But I think my kind
of take on an approach
to recording-- years ago there
were physical limitations.
Limitations in the number of
tracks that a multitrack tape
could offer-- 8 track,
16, whatever it is.
Limitations in time,
the budget that you
had to go into a studio,
now all of those things
are out the window.
You can have as many
tracks as you want
and as much time as
you want, but that
means you never finish anything.
And I think the problem, why so
much kind of own solo recorded,
in every sense of the
word, music sounds
a little bit under par
is that it's overcooked.
You spent too much time on it.
And I think that one thing
you can do to kind of create
the kind of rock
and roll excitement,
which obviously
would be wonderful
if you're doing rock and roll,
is to impose limitations.
Say I'm going to get
it done by tonight.
That's it.
And to inject some
excitement or be it falsely,
but I think that is an
approach which can be good.
ALAN PARSONS: There
was an experiment
done maybe three
or four years ago
with Geoff Emerick, the
original Beatles engineer,
with a couple of bands who
effectively re-recorded
a couple of Beatles' songs.
Did anybody see this
documentary about this?
It was fairly well protected.
I don't think a lot
of people saw it.
But the discipline for a
modern band in the studio
is, I mean, a guy sings
his heart out flat
all the way through.
And the producer
says, it sucked.
Come and have a listen.
We'll fix it.
And these bands were really
having quite a hard time
actually getting through an
entire song, playing together,
and then having to do complete
vocal performances and stuff
like that.
The way it used to be.
And that's an indication we've
become very forgiving, I think,
of what talent is.
There are a lot of extremely
mediocre talent out there
that make millions.
And it's because the technology
allows them to be that way.
It's really true now.
And, you know, it's
not as if I don't
take advantage of those things.
I mean, I use autotune just like
everybody else but sparingly.
JULIAN COLBECK: Don't you
think also that to some degree
your character is defined
by your limitations.
So if you can't have no
limitations because you're
perfectly in tune
and perfectly in time
it's probably going
to sound dull as mud.
I mean, what makes a
performance exciting
is that you're on the edge,
you're almost falling off,
you get back.
That's what creates
that kind of energy.
So I think imperfections
are good and should
be justly protected.
Leave them in.
I mean, there's a space of
multitracks floating around
on the internet.
You can hear all of John
Lennon's solo vocals
and everybody's kind of revealed
in naked form these days,
but if you hear those tracks,
I mean, the vocal take
on "Imagine", I mean he's
up and down in pitch.
It's all over the place.
But it was an
incredible performance.
But if you do what you do
now, which is solo everything,
everything can be viewed
in isolation and processed.
That performance would have
never been allowed to happen.
And that's pretty
obviously crazy
because it was good
that it did happen.
So I think limitations
are worth preserving.
And also, one quick other thing,
you mentioned psychoacoustics,
I think that one of the things
that the brain, what music is,
comedown to that fairly
deep kind of idea.
If you have repetition,
it will kind of
put your brain to sleep.
If you hear a ticking
clock, you will eventually
just not hear it.
Or a train constantly
running past the door.
It is sound changing that
keeps that tickles the ear
and keeps it interesting.
ALAN PARSONS: That was
one of the premises
that MP3 was based on.
We only take away what
the ear can't discern.
JULIAN COLBECK: Right.
They say.
ALAN PARSONS: But clearly
they got it wrong.
JULIAN COLBECK: Right.
Exactly.
That's a pretty big kind
of imposition to make.
ALAN PARSONS: If I just
could rant a little bit more
about MP3.
It is such a shame that
iTunes and even Google Play
are still essentially
based on MP3.
On my own website I'm
offering our latest release
in high resolution,
24-bit, as a WAV
file for less
money than the MP3.
[APPLAUSE]
So I think if people could
be educated to simply listen
to the differences
between MP3 and WAVs
or high resolution files over
a period of time, I mean,
an MP3 it's OK.
It's OK.
It's all there.
But where is the magic?
It does just suck out
the magic from the music.
And that's terribly sad.
And there are streaming
services out there
which are pretty good.
I mean, they're
still compressed.
They use a lot more of
the data than an MP3 does.
I've been listening
to Slacker lately.
I think it sounds really
good compared to-- Oh,
the winner of the worse sound
of all is satellite radio.
I hope none of you are renewing
your subscriptions to XM radio,
to Sirius XM because
it totally sucks.
But I just want to
see a brighter future
as we progress in digital
audio and downloads and stuff.
The capability of
high quality is there.
It's just that we're
worried about taking
20 minutes to download a
song instead of 3 minutes
and taking up extra
space in our hard drives.
Hard drives are getting
bigger, why worry?
So I just encourage everybody
to look at high definition audio
and let's improve what
we're listening to.
Sir.
AUDIENCE: First of all,
thanks for coming in.
ALAN PARSONS: Oh,
you're very welcome.
AUDIENCE: I'm a big fan
of your work both behind
and in front of the console.
And I wanted to ask you a
little bit about that, which
is how much did your knowledge
of capturing and reproducing
sound inform your
own music work?
ALAN PARSONS: I think it
was very, very important.
But I'm a little
bit of a passenger
when it comes to
playing on stage.
I know my background is
in producing, engineering.
It just so happens I can play
three chords on the guitar
and so I get away
with it on stage.
And I've even come out of my
shell a bit in recent years
and even started singing a bit.
But it all stems from
the learning process,
growing up in recording studios
and seeing what could be done.
I always supported orchestras
and orchestral arrangements
being a part of what I did.
That's been a little bit of a
disappointment over the years
because budgets
just simply don't
allow to have a band
and an orchestra,
although we've done
a couple of shows
with a symphony orchestra,
which have been great.
But there's an influence,
but I surround myself
with great musicians
and they do the work.
I'm actually more there
as a sort of manager,
just like I am in the studio.
I'm kind of the band producer
as opposed to the band leader.
Does that kind of answer?
Good.
AUDIENCE: Coming back
to MP3 and file format.
So MP3 obviously is not good
enough, what is good enough?
I mean, when does
it become overkill?
96 kilo hertz, 192?
DSD?
What would you choose?
ALAN PARSONS: That will
probably remain an argument
forever and a day.
I'm happy with 96 24.
AUDIENCE: What about DSD?
Do you hear the difference?
I know it's hard to edit in DSD.
ALAN PARSONS: I've had
no experience with DSD.
I mean, I think it sounds great.
The disks I've heard in DSD
sound really, really good.
But I have not had
the opportunity
to compare them directly
with any other systems.
But I think DSD is history now?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
I think it's surviving
now online especially.
It's mostly for direct
recording I think,
since you cannot really edit.
So classical music
concerts, one shot.
ALAN PARSONS: Yes.
It was always
traditionally accepted
that if you were a
Hi-Fi nut that you
listen to classical music.
I think that's kind of changed.
I mean, rock music I think has a
place in the audiophile's home.
Rock and pop engineers work just
as hard as classical engineers
to get a good sound,
so why shouldn't we
have the benefit of
audiophile technology?
But it's interesting,
there's always
been this strange dividing line
between pro audio and consumer
Hi-Fi.
And we have completely
different parameters
that seem important to us.
I mean, the Hi-Fi nut
will say my cable has
gold plated connectors
and its oxygen free
and it's only two feet long.
Whereas your cable it doesn't
have gold plated cables
and it's 20 feet long.
Can't you hear the difference?
Nope.
And there were all kinds of
some strange, quirky stuff.
And they're like if
you took a pencil
and you drew a cross on
a CD with this magic pen
and it would sound better.
JULIAN COLBECK: Along
with the [INAUDIBLE],
I think, know what I mean?
ALAN PARSONS: Just
incredible stuff.
But it's good to see
vinyl coming back.
It's good to see that vinyl
is being recognized as a--
JULIAN COLBECK: What's
your take on the high end?
Do you think you can hear
a substantial difference
in the high end on vinyl
as opposed to a CD?
ALAN PARSONS: It's
not just the high end.
Oh, by the way, vinyl, for the
younger people in the audience,
those are those big black CDs.
JULIAN COLBECK:
It's not a suitcase.
ALAN PARSONS: There's
one over there.
JULIAN COLBECK: It's the
things your dad's briefcase is
made out of.
ALAN PARSONS: You
know, analog, vinyl, it
has that vibrancy that does
get lost in digital recordings.
That's coming from somebody
who supports digital recording.
I've been recording
digitally ever
since I could back
in the mid '80s.
JULIAN COLBECK: But vinyl
had a problem with bass
though didn't it?
I mean you couldn't
put the level of bass
that an EDM artist would
now find essential,
you couldn't count
that could you?
I wouldn't have though.
ALAN PARSONS: No.
In fact, I talked to Geoff
Emerick, the Beatles engineer,
at [INAUDIBLE]
just the other day.
And he said there's a
lot of current recordings
which are simply uncuttable
to vinyl because there are
phase problems and
excessive bass.
That it just can't be done
without cutting the level way,
way down.
That was some in
criticism to the fact
that engineers aren't
trained like they used to be.
I mean, Jeff and I both started
at the bottom at Abbey Road,
you know, working in
the tape library then.
Moving on to sessions as
tape ops, button pushers,
as I mentioned earlier.
And then most assisted
engineers then
became cutting room engineers.
They would go and cut
for a couple of years.
Cut vinyl.
I actually skipped that step,
but Jeff was a great mastering
engineer as well as
a great recording
engineer in later years.
But that was the
way the training
happened at Abbey Road.
And it was very valuable.
And it just speaks
for itself, I think,
that so many engineers--
myself included--
made a name for
themselves because
of that great background.
AUDIENCE: So my
question is mainly
on the consumer technology.
If you listen to $1,000 set up,
$5,000, to $20,000 to $50,000
to $100,000 set up, you
hear material difference.
And so it looks like even good
music is going to the elite.
And our profession,
and engineers
and our side basically software
developers, our main focus
is to make sure that the
software is for the masses,
not just for the elite.
Do engineers on the audio
side have such consciousness
to or not?
JULIAN COLBECK: Absolutely.
ALAN PARSONS: There was
always this argument,
is music on a better system
more enjoyable because it's
on a better system?
The answer is no.
If the music is there and
the information is not
being sucked out of it by
digital media, digital means,
then, you know,
I listen to music
at home on a
receiver from Costco.
The speaker is this size.
I enjoy it just as much
as I do in the studio.
One of the sad things about
the way listening to music
for the consumer has
gone in recent years
is you can't get people
to sit down and listen
to 50 minutes of music anymore.
The phone rings, they've got
their email to catch up on.
They've got 500 TV
channels to watch.
They've got video games.
They've got all these
incredible distractions.
The concept of
buying a shiny new LP
and taking it home, putting
it on the record player,
turning the lights down,
lighting up a cigarette,
and just spending a
little while listening.
Those days are gone.
People don't do that anymore.
And I would really like to see
that coming back, if possible.
JULIAN COLBECK: I think also
just to close on your point.
There's a difference
between the system used
to create a piece of music and
a system used to simply hear
what has been created.
And I think if you had a
very modest system that
was used to create
the piece of music,
it would be very difficult to
get the kind of high quality
recordings on a very Lo-Fi
or modest playback system.
But if you've created it well,
then I think, as Alan said,
it can translate.
And in the studio that
was a very important part
to play a track back in mono, to
play a track on small speakers,
and to make sure that the energy
that was in there being played
on these enormous
speakers where there
is fantastic quality,
still translated.
And so I think to
answer your question,
engineers did, and were,
and are very mindful of that
not everybody is listening
to them like that.
ALAN PARSONS:
Unfortunately the consumer
has a record of always
getting it wrong.
Consumer chose VHS over Betamax,
they chose DVD over Laser Disk.
Laser Disk was far superior.
They chose cassette
over 8 tracks.
8 tracks were superior.
Just making that point.
And they've now chosen MP3s.
AUDIENCE: CD is way superior.
Those are WAV files.
ALAN PARSONS: Indeed.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So MP3s.
Why do they listen
to so many MP3s?
ALAN PARSONS: You tell me.
JULIAN COLBECK: Well, they're
easier to move around.
ALAN PARSONS: It's
just convenience.
And it's great in
professional circles.
MP3s are a godsend.
I send my own tracks
around to musicians
so they can learn
songs and stuff.
It's ideal.
But when it comes to sitting
down and being entertained,
the high res audio
needs to be appreciated.
It really does.
AUDIENCE: So I've
heard both of you
talk about a couple
times about how
something when it sounds good.
And I have to guess that
what your opinion of what
sounds good was informed
by years and years
in the studio coming
up from being a tape op
and being an assistant
engineer and all that.
Any words of advice on how
jerks like me in my bedroom
can start to develop that skill
to understand what sounds good?
And, obviously,
there's a personal--
ALAN PARSONS: There's
this marvelous book.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIAN COLBECK: Oh, Alan.
AUDIENCE: I was afraid you
were going to say that.
ALAN PARSONS: And a DVD series.
That's really why we did
the book and the DVD.
Just to try and lift
the veil a little bit
and lift the mysteries
of the recording studio.
JULIAN COLBECK: But I think one
of the things that Alan said,
which I definitely pass on is
just learning how to listen.
And one of the things he did
at Abbey Road like any engineer
there would do is orchestra one
day, rock band the next day,
spoken word.
All day long you're
being exposed
to different sounds,
different music.
And over the course
of time, hey presto,
like being fit as an
athlete, you are trained.
I think that learning
how to listen
is certainly a sort of thread.
ALAN PARSONS: Interestingly,
when I first started,
of course, everything
sounded great
because it was coming out of
this wonderful studio system.
And then this engineer gets a
different kind of piano sound
to this engineer and that's
because he uses this mic, that
mic, he positions
it this certain way.
So it was just a constant
learning process.
And then you develop
your own style
through watching other people.
And suddenly it wasn't
just good sound every day.
It was a good
piano sound, not so
good vocal sound,
nice guitar sound.
And then you just meld all
the influences together
and create your own
engineering identity.
JULIAN COLBECK: Yeah.
It's just developing your
own I think isn't it?
Really, at the end of the day.
When we made the DVD series,
one of the scenes and chapters
in the books was a
band tracking session.
It was a really
interesting experience
because Alan wrote a song, did
a little demo on a keyboard.
We got wonderful musicians in
a studio to learn this song
and to play it.
And so we're in the studio
and he plays the song
and they're all, OK, and
the take down some notes.
And they got a
little chord chart
and off they go into the
studio and start running
through this song which
they had never before.
And it kind of just
sounded more or less
like the demo on a
keyboard and it was OK.
And Alan calls them
back into the room
after a few minutes
of going through that.
And he just says,
well, maybe just
try-- make these tiny, tiny
little adjustments to what
people are playing, the
sound, et cetera, et cetera.
They went back into
the room and it
sounded like a Alan
Parsons record.
Just like that.
It's like, we had had a
time warp or something.
I mean, it was
just extraordinary.
But it was just Alan's taste.
I mean, he likes what he likes.
It's probably quite difficult
to define what you like.
But he knows what
he likes and he
knows how to get what he
likes on whatever equipment
he's looking at.
And I think, yeah, you
asked what you could do.
And I think it's just learning
how to listen and develop
your own taste.
That's probably a good place.
ALAN PARSONS: It's a funny
thing because I don't go out
intentionally to make
records sound like me,
but people tell me that my
records do sound like me.
But I don't know why.
I can't actually
pinpoint what it is.
JULIAN COLBECK: Well, it's
just your taste isn't it?
I mean, you like a certain
thing and therefore he
gets the certain
sound that he likes.
And I think we all do that
in our day-to-day lives.
ALAN PARSONS: I know I was
talking about Abbey Road
engineers.
You could hear a record
and you could say, oh,
that's one of Peter Vince's,
or that one's Peter Brown's.
That's Geoff Emerick.
Engineers did have a style.
I think that's gone a
little bit in today's market
because there's just
so much music out there
and everybody's using the
same equipment, same plugins,
same basic premises
to create what
is considered to be
commercial in today's market.
JULIAN COLBECK: But
isn't also that they
are dependent on
the same equipment
and dependent on the
same plugins as opposed
to dependent on these things?
ALAN PARSONS: Yeah.
Ears are very important.
I did discover that early on.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
about the process of mixing for
a surround sound experience?
And in a somewhat
related question,
have you ever done
a mix specifically
for headphone listening?
ALAN PARSONS: Surround, I mean,
I love mixing for surround.
I've unfortunately not
done much of my own music,
apart from two albums, which
we mixed on air in surround.
But none of the Alan Parson's
Projects yet exist in surround.
I did two of Al Stewart's
bigger hits, "Year
of the Cat" and "Time
Passages," but for some reason
they've never been released.
You just reminded me that
I need to make a phone
call about that.
I love surround.
The sad thing is
that so many people
have home theaters with
surround systems for movies,
but are almost
unaware that there's
a wealth of music out
there that deserves
to be heard in surround.
You may be surprised to
hear that mixing surround is
actually easier than
mixing in stereo
because there's something
about music coming
from all directions that makes
balance a little bit more
forgiving.
Subtleties of balance are
more forgiving in surround
than they are in stereo.
As you'll see in
the book, I've never
been a supporter of
the center channel.
And I very rarely put
anything of importance
in the center channel.
I much rather use
the phantom center.
That most of my
surround material,
if you listen to the
central channel on its own,
it will be most of
the time just a mix
of the left and
right front channels.
But it's a big subject.
And thank you for
at least raising it,
but I wish labels would
put more money into it.
I wish artists would
show more interest in it.
And I wish consumers would just
go out and buy the stuff that's
there because it really
is such good fun.
I've always said that
listening in surround
is like listening to
stereo after mono.
It's the same leap.
The same jump.
AUDIENCE: What about mixes
specifically for headphones?
ALAN PARSONS: Oh, right.
Headphones.
I'm always checking every
mix I do on headphones.
I think far too many people are
listening to Lo-Fi headphones--
little white things
stuck in their ears.
But it's just there is a
difference in the hearing
experience between
headphones and speakers.
But I will always check to make
sure there are no surprises.
I mean, headphones
tend accentuate reverb.
I find sometimes that I might
back off reverb a little bit
when listening on headphones.
But you have to compromise.
I can't do a mix
especially for headphones.
Why would I do that?
AUDIENCE: The
thunderstorm on "Tales
of Mystery and
Imagination" was recorded
by an aural microphone
[INAUDIBLE].
ALAN PARSONS: Yeah.
Yeah.
That sounds good on
headphones doesn't it?
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans
to release the Alan Parson's
records in high def?
Like maybe give them the
King Crimson treatments
that Steve Wilson has done?
ALAN PARSONS: I would
like to see that happen.
I'm sort of in the
midst of a renegotiation
with my label and my publisher.
So as soon as we
get through that,
I'm going to try and get some
high def downloads available.
And if no one takes them
up, I'll take them myself.
I'll license them myself.
Good.
OK.
Sold one copy.
All right.
WESLEY CHAN: All right.
We have just a minute left.
Is there one final
question that people have?
AUDIENCE: You have a
little chapter on MIDI,
but I noticed you didn't
have like the little charts
and bars.
So how much are you into MIDI?
Some people think of it
as an ancient technology,
but I think it's like WAVs.
It actually is pretty
smart and still being used.
ALAN PARSONS: Julian
is the MIDI man.
JULIAN COLBECK: I
think I actually
did write the
first book on MIDI.
But anyway.
MIDI is like electricity.
I mean, it's a tool.
It's a means to an end.
Is electricity good?
Does it sound good?
I mean, MIDI doesn't
sound good or bad.
It isn't good or bad.
It's a tool.
In good hands, I mean, MIDI
is just unbelievably powerful
and unbelievably creative.
And it's still there
in kind of version 1.0.
I mean there is threatening
things happening at the moment,
but essentially it's still
there in its original format.
ALAN PARSONS: We can't say that
for much software out there.
JULIAN COLBECK: That's right.
1983 to now and it
hasn't changed at all.
That is unbelievable.
It's kind of difficult
to get your head around,
so I think MIDI's problem
is being that people either
misinterpret it or don't
use it because they
are kind of befuddled by it.
AUDIENCE: Well, if
you have the ear,
you could do a track
that is super solid
and drag the snare a little bit.
And stuff like that.
JULIAN COLBECK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Stuff that you
couldn't get that drummer
to do.
ALAN PARSONS: I don't see
that as being a MIDI thing,
I see that as being a DAW thing.
AUDIENCE: A production thing.
ALAN PARSONS: Yeah.
JULIAN COLBECK: Well, I
developed some software
Twiddly.Bits which
are these little what
we call MIDI samples.
And these were MIDI recordings
of drummers and bass players
and guitar players using MIDI
drums, MIDI bass, MIDI guitars.
And one of the
things we did early,
I was playing with Bill Bruford,
from King Crimson and YES,
and we recorded him on a Simmons
kit-- a sophisticated STX kit.
And Bill sounds like Bill on any
kit you care to name in MIDI.
You can just feel his heartbeat.
He's always slightly
ahead on the snare,
slightly behind
on the kick drum.
That's his DNA.
So, I mean, MIDI I
think has the capability
of displaying your DNA as
a player, as a performer.
And that's really fascinating.
ALAN PARSONS: And it
still forms the basis
of so much more than just
keyboards and samples.
Mixing automation is
based on MIDI largely.
My console at home
it uses MIDI to talk
to other components
in the system.
So it's not all about
punching notes onto a screen
or telling one keyboard
to play another keyboard.
It goes way beyond that.
AUDIENCE: And still well.
ALAN PARSONS: And
still version 1.0.
WESLEY CHAN: All right.
Great.
Thanks for the question.
All right, everybody,
let's thank Alan and Julian
for coming by today.
[APPLAUSE]